je vous l'avais dit
c'est parti c'est parti pour la première
édition
bien
pour un petit d'accord comme ça
et en vous voyant là je viens de me
rappeler que j'ai rêvé de vous cette
nuit dis donc je vous jure racontez-moi
vous ouvriez une boutique de Guy rose en
Grèce 2 de Guy rosser comme les lépitas
avec un peu comme les kebabs mais en
mode grec hésitez bon bah je sais pas ce
weekend se jouer la 35e journée du
championnat de France de Ligue 1 dernier
match avant la journée mondiale de lutte
contre l'homophobie c'est mercredi le 17
mai à cette occasion toutes les équipes
portaient d'un maillot sur lequel le
numéro était aux couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel lors du match Toulouse -
Nantes plusieurs joueurs des deux
équipes n'ont pas été alignés sur le
terrain il refusait de porter ce maillot
et de soutenir de fait la lutte contre
les discriminations faites aux personnes
LGBT c'était le trophée mais surtout
porter un message de diversité d'espoir
d'amour d'un sport qui me fait vibrer et
qui doit être ouvert à tous
on porte tous le même maillot arborer
des numéros arc-en-ciel posé devant une
bannière trop pour une poignée de
joueurs hier trois Toulousains et à
Nantes et ont tout simplement refusé
le respect est une valeur que je porte
en haut estime cela s'applique aux
autres mais aussi à mes propres
croyances je ne pense pas être la
personne adaptée pour participer à cette
campagne ce soit pas le rapport en fait
je ne vois pas le rapport en
l'homophobie je ne vois pas
heureusement qu'on a lutté depuis des
décennies contre l'obscurantisme des
religions et des croyances pour être un
peu tolérant bah oui l'égalité entre les
uns et les autres vu mes racines ma
culture l'importance de mes convictions
et croyances il n'était pas possible
pour moi de participer à cette campagne
une position qui fait réagir jusqu'au
porte-parole du gouvernement
c'est nul
donc il faut sanctionner ces joueurs
pour refuser
une société française européenne où
chacun est libre de s'aimer comme il le
souhaite
alors je le fais en plus à l'embrasse
bien Solène elle est belle c'est vrai
que c'était fun le 1er bisous qu'on a eu
et ben avec plaisir de la rue embrasser
pas de place pour les discriminations ni
dans le foot ni dans la vie mais je
pense aussi que nous sommes là pour
jouer au football et c'est ça qui est le
plus important on a tous conscience de
ça et que c'est pas la peine de vouloir
afficher tout le temps on peut aussi
avoir plein d'autres causes pour
lesquelles on pourrait jouer toutes les
semaines avec des maillots différents en
gros on est contre les discriminations
mais laissez-nous jouer au foot
notre langue en embrassant chacun une
personne que l'on souhaite
plusieurs personnes voilà
on a étiré les lèvres l'école c'est le
pire moment le collège le lycée c'est
des moments où vous entendez ces mots ou
vous essayez de vous planquer parce que
le moment où vous êtes repéré là c'est
le défouloir et là tous ces mots là vous
allez les entendre toute la journée tous
les jours et ça c'est commun à peu près
tous les témoignages qu'on retrouve dans
le documentaire et reste l'insulte la
plus prononcée dans une cour de récré
aujourd'hui en 2023 à ce qui paraît
dingue quand même
manger ma banane tout nue sur la plage
et c'est simplement tes outils qui sont
toujours mal nettoyés mal préparés non
non mais ça va pas du tout donc je pars
je nettoie j'arrange bref je passe
derrière et je rectifie voilà ma vie
voilà ma vie
[Rires]
on vous éduque en tout cas on vous met
dans un moule pour vous faire comprendre
que ces gens-là parce qu'effectivement
ces gens là c'est The Moon ne sont pas
normaux ne sont voilà donc oui il y a un
moment effectivement on doute on se pose
énormément de questions c'est un moment
en plus alors peut-être qu'avec les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui Internet
c'est différent mais moi je n'avais
personne à qui en parler personne donc
vous retrouvez tout seul face à vos
questions d'adolescents déjà qui sont
assez nombreuses il a en plus se rajoute
tout ça moi absolument rien contre
personne simplement faut pas m'emmerder
promis tout va bien se passer
il est méprisant il ne sait pas nous
parler et il nous prend de haut vous
l'avez entendu mille fois
que ça a amené chez vous non pas un
examen de conscience est-ce que vous
dites ils sont peut-être un peu raison
écoutez j'aime pas sa tête qu'on met à
toutes les choses Emmanuel Macron qui a
reçu ce matin un invité surprise Elon
Musk le patron de Tesla SpaceX et
Twitter a rencontré le chef de l'État à
l'Élysée accueille chaleureux vous le
voyez et entrevue entre les deux hommes
avant de participer au sommet tchuss
France traduisez choisir la France
auxquels sont conviées plus de 200 PDG
de multinationales à Versailles mais
l'adjectif méprisant je le récuse parce
que on va pas au contact comme je vais
depuis que je suis engagé dans la vie
politique quand on a du mépris pour les
gens et je vais vous dire quand on a du
mépris on s'en fiche le vrai mépris
c'est de mentir aux gens le 2 on y va
pour 8 points il joue au brave
tonde liée secrétaire d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts hier sur France 3 elle a
attaqué la chaîne cnews en arguant que
toute la journée il y aurait des débats
entre
extrême droite et de droite extrême
comme beaucoup de personnes malentenées
madame tondeuilliez parle de ces news
sans jamais regarder la chaîne écouter
nos émissions à moi à moins qu'elle
éruque la natam pour défigurer notre
chaîne on commence à se connaître après
deux mois on sent très très bien la
complicité un moment donné on met un
petit bruitage quel qu'il soit on sait
qu'elle va partir
voilà c'est c'est voilà c'est le genre
de bruitage on sait que si on a besoin
de la revigorer un peu Philippe Bilger
exprime souvent une opinion
conservatrice mais à la différence de
Madame tourdelier il ne tombe jamais
dans la caricature ni dans la
malhonnêteté intellectuelle j'écoute
elisabeth Lévy depuis 7 ans que lors des
pro existe je suis incapable de la
placer sur l'échiquier politique je la
vois comme une empêcheuse de tourner en
rond comme une sorte d'annare entre
esprit libertaire conviction libérale et
chasseuse du politiquement correct entre
votre fille et certains bruitages on
sait comment la booster votre femme
c'est Jérôme un petit bruit de PET aussi
ce serait bien aussi
on va terminer quelque chose de beaucoup
plus léger à présent avec cette
explosion à plombière dans les
expositions à l'exposition
le début le milieu la fin la chanson
rien à marcher et avant vivement Marie
Myriam comme un enfant